[Musique]
merci de nous rejoindre sur tv soixante
dix huit pour un nouveau numéro de v y
fait un numéro aujourd'hui plutôt
politique bonjour didier fischer reset
ce merdeux coignard vice-président de 50
ans en charge de l'action sociale mère
d'une liste sans étiquette mais vous
êtes de sensibilité de gauche
voilà on va présenter les choses comme
ça vous avez revêtu votre écharpe le 9
décembre dernier un peu plus de dix ans
après votre première candidature aux
municipales sur cette commune
puisqu'avant vous militiez sur
rambouillet non loin de coignières vous
avez un sou vient justement de ce départ
de rambouillet de votre arrivée à
coignières ya une dizaine d'années
souvenir non le disons enfin souvenirs
je ne sais pas si si si c'est un
souvenir mais bon bah notre famille je
dirais s'agrandissait les enfants
grandissaient on avait un petit logement
à rambouillet et on cherchait
effectivement quelque chose de plus de
plus vaste de plus grands chercher un
logement de 100 à 120 mètres carrés est
sûre on bouillait c'était très cher
l'époque c'était personnel j'avais un
stage et qui étaient autour de trois
cent mille euros fallait compter cinq
cent mille euros pour voir quelque chose
de très bien sûr rambouillet donc
ensuite j'ai regardé un peu sur la ligne
de chemin de fer puisque l'idée c'était
quand même d'avoir un axe de transport
et j'ai regardé opérait aux essarts et
puis je suis arrivé à coignières voilà
c'est un peu le hasard qui a fait que je
suis arrivé à coignières mais vous avez
décidé de continuer à vous engager en
politique toujours j'ai toujours essayé
pas mal j'ai été là quand vous êtes
maintenant à coignières grand salan
quand je suis quand je suis arrivé
effectivement dudit bomba j'arrive à
coignières je m'engage politiquement
effectivement à coignières serait
arrivée aux essarts c'était la même
chose j'aurais fait exactement la même
chose
j'étais dans une dynamique effectivement
d'engagement votre conception de la
politique on ne représentent une
population que si l'on partage ses
aspirations son cadre de vie sont vos
mots qui viennent de votre de votre blog
ça date de 2008 justement alors cette
conception de la politique ça veut dire
que pour vous un élu est au plus proche
de ses concitoyens et du mans 7e vie et
est déconnecté exactement je pense que
c'est l'essentiel je ne comprends pas
ces mères qui ne résident pas par
exemple dans leur commune ça c'est pour
moi c'est incompréhensible
j'ai quitté rambouillet je ne
m'imaginais pas continuer je dirais un
engagement politique à rambouillet quand
je suis arrivé à rambouillet je me suis
engagé politiquement à rambouillet voyez
c'est pour moi il faut qu'on vive ce que
nos concitoyens vivent pour les
comprendre pour comprendre et pour agir
et agir au plus près en effet de la
population c'est toujours été ma
conception je suis très proche des gens
et votre engagement politique lui
remonte à quand trésor mon engagement
politique où il remonte très jeune mais
je n'étais pas encarté dans un parti
mon engagement remonte
au lycée dans les années dans les années
soixante dix à la fin des années 70
c'était un engagement plus tôt
d'ailleurs associatif que politique au
sens strict du terme ont milité contre
le nucléaire à l'époque on était plutôt
vers pour et
et aussi je dirais on me dit tu es pour
plus de justice sociale bien entendu
c'était un engagement à gauche à
l'époque déjà mais vous avez pris votre
carte au parti socialiste
alors en 1996 voyez c'est tardif moi je
suis quelqu'un qui arrive dans un parti
politique à l'âge presque plus que mû en
rêvait donc c'est quand même
relativement tardif c'est vous les
regardez cette carte au parti socialiste
allait beaucoup de départs en ces
derniers temps mais sans l'annoncer en
or par conséquent je ne suis plus au
parti socialiste depuis 2017
j'ai quitté le parti socialiste après
l'élection présidentielle
quand j'ai vu la situation qui devenait
vraiment impossible la manière aussi
dont le parti je dirais avaient soutenu
sans candidat il est à l'époque benoît
hamon que j'ai soutenu d'ailleurs je me
suis dit c'est plus possible c'est plus
possible
vous vous imaginez reprendre une carte
c'est dans la partie politique non c'est
terminé
ah non non aujourd'hui non non
aujourd'hui je continue à voir des
engagements politiques
bien entendu c'est ce que je disais
quand je
quand j'ai été
officiellement réservé qu officiellement
l'écharpé tricolore le 9 décembre j'ai
dit jusque-là à coignières a eu des
maires sans étiquette mais de droite
aujourd'hui ils ont un maire sans
étiquette mais de gauche
voilà grosso parce que tout le monde a
compris mais
non je ne m'imagine pas reprendre une
carte dans un parti politique
aujourd'hui l'évolution de la politique
aujourd'hui fait que d'appartenir à un
parti ne signifie plus grand chose
je ne sais pas si ça ne signifie plus
grand chose moi j'admire encore ceux qui
ont la foi chevillée au corps et qu'il
pense que
mais je crois aussi sincèrement qui a
peut-être d'autres manière aussi de
faire évoluer les choses de transformer
la société
les parties ont toute leur raison d'être
mais faut-il encore que il représente
je dirais la population ce qui n'est
plus tout à fait le cas aujourd'hui sur
un plan professionnel vous êtes docteur
en histoire professeur agrégé d'histoire
de géographie au lycée bascans à
rambouillet parlez nous un petit peu
cette passion pour l'histoire avec un
grand h à la passion pour l'histoire oui
ma passion pour l'histoire elle remonte
aussi à ma jeunesse j'avais un père qui
était était un ouvrier lier qui
conduisait les ouvriers au sens je
dirais de l'insee série qu'on disait les
autobus mais mais il avait vécu la
seconde guerre mondiale comme jeune
homme et il était passionné
effectivement par cette histoire
il avait une bibliothèque c'est
remarquable et j'ai plongé dans cette
bibliothèque évidemment tout petit et
l'histoire est venu comme cela cette
transmission paternel a fait que je me
suis intéressé plus particulièrement
effectivement à l'histoire mais je
n'avais pas forcément au départ
l'intention d'être professeur d'histoire
et non visage et même un moment des
professeurs d'éducation physique donc
vous voyez c'est quand même pas
tout à fait tout à fait la même chose
mais le fait l'enseignement était
quelque chose qui m'intéressait vraiment
qui me passionnait alors je sais pas si
parce qu'on peut parler de vocation part
souvent de vocation pour les enseignants
ne sais pas si c'est une vocation parce
que c'est quand même un métier aussi
enseigner ça s'apprend et un mois entre
en plus de 30 ans aujourd'hui se dirait
d'enseignement j'ai beaucoup appris
aussi j'ai fait des bêtises aussi quand
j'étais plus jeune enseignant bon
l'important en fait c'est ce que je dis
souvent aux enseignants qui que j'avais
en responsabilité quand j'avais des
stagiaires dans mes classes maintenant
bon avec la vie politique j'ai moins de
temps à consacrer à la formation des
jeunes dans l'enseignement mais je leur
disais donc disons de comment dire
c'était un métier mais qu'il fallait
aussi qu'ils en sortent c'est à dire que
en fait ne pas faire que de
l'enseignement ayez à côté une passion
une autre chose parce qu'il faut pas que
les échecs de vos élèves soient vos
propres échecs c'est très difficile à
vivre cela vous avez publié des ouvrages
notamment rue publié oui sur les
mouvements étudiants encore sur cette
question sauver l'école de la république
d'ailleurs peut-on la sauver cette école
on voit encore aujourd'hui il ya des des
réformes philippe à g le mannequin
buteur qui a choisi ce titre parce que
bon je suis beaucoup plus nuancée
évidemment dans mon propos par rapport à
l'école de la république
non mais je dirais que la partie
recherche écriture c'est aussi un peu ma
soupape à moi de sécurité en quelque
sorte et c'est vrai que j'ai écrit un
certain nombre d'ouvragés je continue à
l'heure actuelle le dernier ce n'est
publiée en 2018 sur l'union nationale
d'ailleurs à propos de ça et les années
qui viennent mais tu étais un gars de
gauche mais tu écris que sur des sujets
de droite
bon alors je dis bon c'est pas si
l'union nationale est un sujet
spécialement droite alors j'ai regardé
alors effectivement effectivement on
peut on pour l on pourrait dire cela
parce que à part mon histoire sur les
étudiants en france mais il ya quand
même bons éléments qui sont quand même
très à l'aise dans cette histoire c'est
vrai le fait d'avoir écrit sur le lit de
pétain par exemple d'avoir écrit sur
l'homme providentiel et enfin sur
l'union nationale c'est un cycle qui se
clôt et c'est vrai que c'est des sujets
qui serait plus classée à droite qu'à
gauche
mais bon du coup aujourd'hui
je suis en train de travailler sur une
biographie des ongles oui voila je
rééquilibre on en vient à cette action
politique justement en tant que maire
votre mandat vous l'avez pris en cours
puisqu'il va s'achever en 2020 date des
prochaines élections municipales
élu au cours d'un scrutin anticipé est
ce que ça veut dire que la d'ores et
déjà vous préparer la prochaine campagne
en fait c'est difficile d'arriver sur
une une fin de mandat
c'est sûr c'est extrêmement difficile
d'arriver sur une fin de mandat on avait
14 mois on avait un projet quand même il
faut pas il faut pas l'oublier et je
pense qu'on va arriver dans ses 14 mois
à réaliser les promesses que l'on avait
fait au moment de la campagne électorale
pensez pouvoir faire bouger les choses
au service donc vous dans la commune je
pense toujours que la dernière année
d'un mandat et en général il mais nous
c'est typique on arrive effectivement à
la fin du mandat et je pense qu'on doit
on va y arriver
on va y arriver à faire bouger les
choses je pense que les choses sont en
train de changer à l'heure actuelle il
ya un retour quand même à plus de
sérénité
on y rit en ville c'était un des
objectifs quand même essayer de ramener
un peu de calme un peu de sérénité voir
redémarrer enfin respirer en quelque
sorte
eh bien ça je crois qu'on y est c'est
fragile encore d'une entendu mais je
crois qu'on est ensuite
dans bien des domaines aussi on va on va
avancer
on avance à l'heure actuelle sur la
jeunesse c'est une de nos priorités et
je pense que l'on va replacer en quelque
sorte la jeunesse un peu au coeur des
préoccupations de notre commune sans
pour autant négliger les seniors on en
est on enlève en rien aux seniors on va
ajouter aux jeunes sans enlever aux
seniors bien entendu puisqu'on fait un
peu le reproche à dire oui mais les
seniors n'y a plus rien nous n'allons
rien été enlevés bien au contraire
et puis surtout on allait parler de
réhabilitation pendant la campagne sale
et réhabilitation vont se faire je pense
que les la réhabilitation du gymnase a
démarré en novembre là on est dans des
appels d'offres c'est assez bon
évidemment il faut six mois pour lancer
tout sa réalisation du gymnase
réalisation aussi des écoles l'école
pagnol par exemple cet été vivre une
vraie réhabilitation puisqu'on va
changer toutes les huisseries on va
refaire le ravalement enfin bon c'est
des choses qui vont se voir et puis
surtout met en place la au prochain
conseil municipal
on met en place des fameux conseil de
quartier ce que l'on avait aussi promis
pendant la campagne donc
la démocratie participative aussi elle
est en route à coignières à l'heure
actuelle donc pour ça je suis assez
satisfait quand même de cette évolution
maintenant j'espère que les poignées
rien le seront aussi
vous avez aussi exprimé certains
certains une certaine déception
vis-à-vis de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines sur la place
accordée à coignières oui j'ai trouvé
que
j'ai trouvé qu'effectivement le petit
jeu politique
j'allais dire politicien a fait qu on a
comment dire privé coignières d'un
conseiller délégué par exemple puisque
c'était le cas auparavant 1
on a éjecté les représentants de
coignières de la plupart des commissions
c'est quand même pas très brillant on
perde en termes je dirais démocratique
et on a confié évidemment au maire parce
qu'on pouvait pas faire autrement une
vice présidence mais une vice présidence
sans budget l'action sociale n'est pas
du domaine de
la commande hier de la communauté
d'agglomération je trouve pas ça très
glorieux d'un peu en vue politique mais
cela dit la majorité aujourd'hui
coignard est dans l'opposition simard et
celle de l'agglo mairie non messieurs
évidemment si on prend si on considère
oui bien partie moment on fait
l'ouverture d'une certaine façon
bon on admet aussi que je puisse en tant
que vice président et que ma collègue
christine renaud qui est conseiller
communautaire puisse aussi je dirais
exercer
une responsabilité au sein de saint
quentin est une responsabilité qui
veuille dire quelque chose pourquoi ne
m'a t'on pas laisser la santé par
exemple la santé l'action sociale salé
ensemble c'était d'ailleurs la
délégation de la laine catelin santé
action sociale
d'ailleurs je pense que tout le monde
pensait que j'aurai la santé l'action
sociale est un peu la surprise d'action
sociale le sol mais l'action sociale 6-1
jeudi terme c'est un joli mot l'action
sociale donc aujourd'hui il faut qu'il y
ait véritablement une action sociale à
saint quentin en yvelines
d'ailleurs c'est tout le sens de mon
engagement de mon engagement depuis le
plus jeune âge
l'action sociale donc vous aurez de quoi
faire sur les premiers mois entre la
commune l'agglomération j'aurais que
passèrent dans les prochains mois et
puis je pense que les cartes sont
rebattues en 2020 6
mon équipe est reconduite à coignières
je pense qu'à partir de là les six
années qui vont venir seront différentes
aussi à l'échelle de la communauté
d'agglomération merci didier fischer
d'avoir participé à ce numéro de vérité
merci beaucoup
[Musique]